Everything takes away.
I know very few geniuses,
very few,
if any,
who can just show up and be brilliant.
The rest of us,
we have to work hard there.
There is no magic potion.
There is no secret sauce.
It's work and that's a lot of work.
And not to be afraid of work,
but indulge in it.
Take it,
be confident with it.
Work hard.
MMM.
There are certain things that um,
come and time,
you know,
and um,
experience is one of those things that
comes after time.
You need the time,
but you can put yourself in a position
to gain experience by allowing yourself
to voluntarily be a beginner at
something.
Um,
I find that to be a very big character
trait,
very admirable character trait.
Um,
when someone purposefully puts them in
the selves in a position to be a
beginner.
So the CEO of a major corporation says,
you know what?
I don't know how to snowboard.
I'm going to go out there.
And this person,
man or woman who is a commander of a
legions of people perhaps is now on,
on the side of a mountain falling on his
or her ass and having a 16 year old kid
be the teacher.
That's a fantastic position to put
yourself in.
And I think people should constantly
look for ways to voluntarily put
themselves in a position of not knowing,
of being vulnerable,
of saying,
I'm going to learn something here.
I want to be open to this and admit I
don't know how to snowboard.
Please teach me and,
and have an experience and an empowering
a millennial,
a younger generation person to say,
you are my instructor.
You are my teacher,
please do it.
And it's like,
wow,
that's a beautiful thing for human
beings to share is to reach out and say,
no,
you're the boss.
Please show me the way.
Okay,
there's power and confidence.
I male on the other side of the the
table now a lot.
I produce and I direct and I,
right.
Um,
and I can really feel the difference
when someone comes into a room with
confidence.
Okay.
But I want to draw the distinction
between confidence and boastfulness.
Someone who is figuratively pounding
their chest saying how great they are.
That's not confidence.
To me,
that's it's egocentric behavior.
And that makes me push away someone who
boasts about how great they are.
I'm leery about that.
But there's a quiet confidence.
And what I tried to,
to express to millennials,
to younger generation of actors,
writers,
directors,
artists of any kind is to,
is to value your talent.
And I would say to them,
I'd say,
are you talented?
And I hope you say yes.
That's not a boast.
It's,
it's being honest.
Do you go out and tell everybody on the
street,
Hey,
I'm talented,
I'm really talented.
No,
it's for yourself.
It's,
it's,
it's internal.
And you can own that and you can value,
greatly value your own contributions to
something,
your intellect,
your imagination,
your humor,
whatever experience you have so far,
you're young,
you'll gain more experience.
That's great.
Be Confident in that.
Um,
when I sense confidence,
I want more from that person.
I,
I do the reaching and um,
I think that's a,
a great lesson.
I just came back from a Uso tour and
talking to only millennials and you
know,
millennials have been maligned a lot
thinking that,
you know,
you've been,
you've been given the the bullshit line
of,
Oh,
you just want the trophy.
You just want to show up and you'll get
a trophy.
You're not really willing to work for
it.
You're not,
and that I just don't buy into that.
Just don't listen to any of that.
Um,
I was so impressed with these young men
and women in the military,
in this case,
commanding great presence,
confidence,
nobility,
kindness.
My wife and I said,
I think we're going to be okay.
Truly.
It's like,
Oh,
if this is,
if this is the next generation of
leaders,
we're going to be okay.
We really are.
We're going to be fine.
Um,
you know,
I think every generation looks to the
next one and says,
oh,
they're not like us.
We were better.
I know you guys are fine,
but there is,
there is definite value in work.
I knew that when I was starting out as
an actor,
I was all about work.
It was like,
and I still am.
I love it.
But that's the,
that's the key.
If,
if you find something that you love to
do,
then when Monday comes along,
you're not going Monday.
You're like,
Monday,
I get to act.
That was great for me.
I love Mondays.
Mm.